Donald Trump ran a major major campaign
saying he is going to drain the swamp of
course it was BS but it was part of the
sort of ethics and moral reforms that
Donald Trump claimed that he would do
the lobbyist ban which we talked about
which is mostly meaningless because of
the way that it's worded we get to the
first day of the hundred and fifteen
Congress yesterday and House Republicans
decide to go right in directly and
weaken the independent Ethics watchdog
the office of congressional ethics also
known as OCE they approved the day
before their first day in the new
Congress the some official rules that
would rein in the power of the office of
congressional ethics immediately Donald
Trump went to not his press person not
the New York Times or whatever he went
to Twitter which is where Donald Trump
goes and he starts retaliating against
House Republicans let's look at those
tweets Trump tweeting with all that
Congress has to work on do they really
have to make the weakening of the
independent Ethics watchdog as unfair as
it's going on to the second tweet maybe
they're number one act and priority he
used a period instead of a question mark
of course grammar and punctuation not
exactly the champ not exactly championed
by Trump's Twitter account focus on tax
reform Trump says health care and so
many other things of far greater
importance hashtag DTS which of course
stands for drain the swamp which is the
opposite of what Donald Trump is doing
bottom line here Republican infighting
is good it's very very good Trump versus
Republicans is a really good thing
because it will get in the way of Donald
Trump being able to achieve the crazy
stuff that he claims to want to do it
also provides and I mentioned this I
don't know if it was November 9th
November 10th maybe when there is an
opportunity for progressives to agree
with Trump then you should actually take
that take that opportunity and do it
Democrats and other ethics groups were
critical of the Republican Party trying
to weaken the ethics watchdog that
happens to coincide with Donald Trump's
point of view and I believe that even
though we are going to be fighting Trump
everywhere where it makes sense to fight
him if there is an area of overlap take
advantage of it because it will not only
be a good thing if we agree with
something Trump is trying to do then we
want him to do it it will also create
more Republican infighting and that is a
very very good thing for progressives
now here's where this story gets even
wackier Donald Trump's campaign manager
for I guess former campaign manager
Kellyanne Conway she seemed to be either
confused or off-message on this and she
was interviewed and she defended the
house deciding to weaken the ethics
watchdog group but she cited of course
this non-existing mandate as the reason
to do it take a look at this video I
haven't discussed this with the
president-elect directly but let's make
sure clear that you're still gonna have
an office of complaint review of the
Republicans have been given the majority
in the House and the Senate all the
governor goes to the governorships
they've won over 1,000 state legislative
seats under President Obama's watch so
there's a mandate there for them to make
significant changes that is the way to
start gutting the independent ethics
office again gutting it doesn't mean
that there won't be a mess yeah this is
even better right Trump and Conway on
two different pages at least temporarily
Trump and House Republicans on different
pages the confusion and the chaos is one
way to try to prevent Donald Trump from
doing really bad things I see this Pat
as a big opportunity for progressives
the pushing of this Republican
infighting yeah and you gotta love that
quote by Kellyanne Conway saying that
the Republicans have this big mandate
yeah I mean I'm at least willing to
entertain that argument are you but the
idea that the establishment has as full
rein to to get rid of like the oversight
yeah watch committee there's no reason
to do that the the successful campaigns
of Donald Trump and Bernie Sanders were
because people were sick of the
establishment yeah that no this is a
good point which is even if you can
successfully declare that a mandate
exists and I believe that you can't even
if you can do that that doesn't open the
door to say we're just going to destroy
any check and balance we want in
government because we have a mandate
right let's let's grant as pat is doing
here that the mandate
you don't get to say hey you know what
Republicans elected us and we're
Republicans let's scrap the Constitution
because after all we have a mandate you
can't just use the perceived mandate
which doesn't exist in this case to do
whatever you want there is every
indication that this administration will
be an unorganized gongshow the way that
the Trump campaign was the way that the
Donald Trump transition team has been
and it could allow progressives to block
when necessary and to actually do
something when it's possible and any
opportunity not only I I've said this
before and I think it really needs to be
stated clearly not only does it make
sense to take advantage of Donald
Trump's position when even because he's
just feeling around in the dark maybe it
coincides with what progressives would
want we should push him to do it and
agree with him because we want the
policy but also because if you were
establishment Republicans and you see
Trump doing something that doesn't
hugely resonate with you and then
Democrats are agreeing with Trump that
will anger establishment Republicans
with Trump ideally make them even more
unwilling to work with him that is a
great thing and progressives need to be
pushing that discuss this and any other
stories that you want to on our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash reddit that is re d di t we will
take a break and coming up next there is
a new poll which asks Americans in which
areas do you trust Trump to handle the
affairs as president of the country the
numbers are very scary but not
altogether surprising that's after the
break
Gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low used price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash t
pS the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included there's
no contracts and you can rent games
through the mobile app get the free
30-day trial for the David Pakman show
audience and support our show by going
to Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s